j'ai soutenu dès 2012 nicolas sarkozy
donc je ne suis plus au programme ni au
rassemblement national et je vais vous
dire tout simplement pourquoi parce
qu'on a considéré que ma place il ya
près de cinq ans et devait se situer à
fond de cale donc certes donne le bon
positionnement vis-à-vis du front
national dont on ne peut pas dire que je
suis ça qu'est ce qui s'est passé si
voulez quand vous avez quelqu'un qui dit
d'un train propos que votre place est à
fond de cale et qu on vous compare parce
que vous avez un parcours militaire qui
est le mien j'en suis fier et je ne
renie pas et qu on vous compare
pas bokassa mais mobutu pourrait céder
vos besoins bobek donc si vous laissez
c'est du genre c'est plus agréable et ça
démontre en fait la vraie nature donc
c'est quelque chose qui ne manie pas moi
par contre aujourd'hui ce qui m'anime
avec zemmour c'est toujours la même
passion de cette france là volonté de la
servir la volonté on sent qu'à travers
le récit le propos il ya l'amour de
cette france profonde il ya l'amour des
régions il ya l'amour du terroir il ya
l'amour du de la langue et puis c'est le
même parcours ce que beaucoup de gens
oubliés alors on dit que c'est d'abord
un écrivain c'est pas le polémiste vous
dites que dans ce cas là le cas entre
guillemets pour dire du bien dit que
c'est un polémiste non c'est un auteur
c'est un écrivain à succès et je crois
que ça fait ça parle aux français ça
parle d'un électorat ce qui est à la
fois les déçus de défi de fillon les
désabusés de marine le pen au regard de
son de son débat du deuxième tour on se
demande encore aujourd'hui comment elle
peut prétendre à la présidence de la
république et puis un nouvel électorat
qui est un électorat qui va être
chercher mon avis qui va ce qui se
manifeste déjà qui est dans les
abstentionnistes ce que tout le monde
oublie aujourd'hui c'est que le premier
quand ce sont les abstentionnistes et ce
sont ces derniers qui se sont pas
mobilisés entre autres aussi pour les
élections régionales et qui à mon avis
vont faire mouche dans l'est dans les
semaines à venir et aujourd'hui pourquoi
pourquoi aujourd'hui présent dans les
omniprésents sur les plateaux dans les
analyses mais il n'est pas candidat
c'est ça devrait quand même faire les
marchés marine le pen pour vous c'est
cuit écoutez oui je pense qu on est
enfin je veux dire c'est que
je veux dire c'est qu'on ne joue pas
fameux voilà c'est passé pas mon sujet
mais je pense que face à un eric zemmour
où il ya une qualité il ya un fond il ya
quelque chose qui parle plus que
qu'est ce qui a manqué à marine le pen
alors pour devenir président quelques
cas eric zemmour
c'est bon je pense qu'il ya une près il
ya une constance je pense qu'il ya une
culture générale qui est pas besoin de
qui est qui et pas besoin de la de la
deûle à manifester kwal elles sortent un
amour de l'histoire et qui est et il est
complètement en acier quand il explique
quand il dit en droit condensé son
parcours de il vient de montreuil
familles modestes et
qui est vrai qu'il a été et il démonte
par son parcours il s'est fait lui même
vous étiez très proche de jean-marie
nocquet prochain gtb gong à m'envoyer
lui très
rigoureuse collaborateurs en provence
alpes côte d'azur c'est ça je ne le
renie absolument pas et là vous avez une
photo qui était pour moi historique mais
enfin que je suis étonné que vous ayez
trouvé c'est maintenant au tour de 19
cents à 88 et j'avais évidemment
l'époque plus de jeu j'étais plus
que will smith mais voilà j'ai en tout
cas c'est bon c'est ça pour vous nous
sommes en open il avait une chance
d'être président à l'époque
goûtez moi je me suis engagé toujours
avec passion j'ai toujours la même
fougue pour pour vous nommant eric
zemmour s'est de nouveau jean marie le
pen ça n'a rien à voir enfin c'est en
tout cas il n'y aurait pas aujourd'hui
qu'on soit très clair un eric zemmour si
il n'y avait pas eu je pense à jean
marie le pen parce que c'est quand même
lui qui a porté un certain nombre
d'idées ou de houe de ou d'attitude et
qui a levé en tout cas qui a levé depuis
jean marie le pen n'avait jamais admiré
autant que quelqu'un
je pense que oui je peux le dire
honnêtement oui je pense que j'ai pour
eric zemmour une
admiration parce que je trouve qu'il est
vous l'avez rencontrée je les vues de la
dernière fois il ya 20 ans et pour vous
dire il n'y a plus une vingtaine et je
crois qu'avec et on s'était retrouvés
tous les deux chez une connaissance
commune d'un côté il y avait un la
famille de france côté
valois et de l'autre côté il y avait des
napoléons donc c'était l'union des deux
france à la fois les bonapartistes et
les légitimistes et l'ont fait
il y avait moyen bencher moule et ben
tara qui
s'est passé c'est très bien nous avait
rien c'est en tout cas et il faut
peut-être le dire si certains ont eu
encore des doutes f1 en tout cas de se
se posent des questions que vraiment
être français qu'elle soit très clair
qu'on arrête ce débat aussi aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas une couleur de peau ce
n'est pas une religion un set français
sait quelle que soit sa race sa religion
à sa place à l'option philosophique et
ça je crois que aujourd'hui ce qui nous
unit tous ici c'est ça et c'est cette
histoire là parce que nous je veux dire
quand on ce juste stéphane
vous trouvez pas qu'il est un petit peu
extremis parfois sûr qu'elle saisit
d'eric zemmour sur les prénoms sur sur
l'islam sur ça vous êtes d'accord actu
et surtout moi je ne trouve pas
extrémiste ou en tout cas je le trouve
conservateur met donc ça monsieur
puisque je suis moi-même un conservateur
et je ne dormirai de jean marie le pen
n'est pas très conservateur moi je mets
moi j'ai toujours été conservateur je ne
serai plus jamais été de ma vie
d'extrême droite même si on a voulu nous
il nous a quand même à fumer de cette
connotation marie le pen n'était pas été
au moins mais écoutez et jean marie le
pen je vais pas faire ça aux 100 pages
se sont ingérés enfin je veux dire il a
été élu pour la première fois député
c'est le premier pas mais l'italie
il a été le premier parlementaire
français à être élu un compatriote
d'origine oui à l'origine antillaise qui
elle aussi est jean marie le pen s'est
parlé de la guinée non mais si oui c'est
l'extrême droite
donc c'est pas grave on parle monsieur
le pen il était pas texane droite le pen
mais nous avons de sortir non c'est pas
que ça vient de sortir c'est que je
pense non mais écoutez il s'est
peut-être l'échiquier politique qui a
bougé mais lui je pense pas que pour moi
mais en tout cas